energie sparen das ist die devise der
letzten wochen und mit robert habeck an
seinem arbeitsplatz sieht das so aus das
bedeutet energie sparen seit einigen
pressekonferenz des
wirtschaftsministeriums also hier in dem
puls strich dann manchmal und
verkündet die neuesten verordnung oder
ständig den fragen der journalisten habe
ich hierher gesetzt weil dieser raum
seit sommer nicht mehr klimatisiert wird
und die pressevertreterinnen und kamera
menschen die hier sind schwitzen wie ich
hier es ist grün lässt schwitzen der
robert habeck bei sich am arbeitsplatz
klimaanlage abgedreht in seinem
ministerium und der planung noch viel
mehr energie spar regeln für uns alle
das hier das ist sein energie sparplan
für ganz deutschland und darin steht zum
beispiel dass das dauerhafte offenhalten
von ladentüren und eingangs systeme in
den geschäftsräumen des einzelhandels
ist untersagt und nur ausnahmsweise in
fällen gestattet in denen das
offenhalten für die funktion des
eingangs als notausgang oder fluchtweg
erforderlich ist ordnung ist deutsch
aber noch mal ganz schnell übersetzt
offene ladentüren künftig verboten claus
strunz bei uns im studio
bild-chefredakteur machst du bei diesem
energie sparplan von robert habeck mit
also erstmal muss man schon die frage
stellen welcher mensch auf die idee
kommt überhaupt einen satz zu
formulieren der heißt das dauerhafte
offenhalten von ladentüren und eingangs
systemen geschäftsräumen des landes ist
untersagt es so etwas verrücktes kann
sich wirklich nur ein verrückter beamter
ausdenken oder eben beamter im umfeld
von robert habeck denn das ist ja jetzt
wieder genau das was wir nicht wollen
der staat regiert in die bereiche hier
von einzelhändlern rein die wahrheit ist
doch wenn ich in einzelhandels laden ab
und ich möchte gern nach draußen heizen
ja dann mache ich das und dann zahle ich
ganz viel stromrechnung oder ganz viel
gasrechnung läge es auf die preise um
und mein kunde straft mich dafür ab weil
es bei mir dann zu teuer ist also mache
ich die ladentür vielleicht ab und zu
mal zu aber wenn ich lust habe sie offen
zu halten kann der staat mir nicht
verbieten es zu tun und das löst in mir
als ich das heute zum ersten mal an mich
an das zuerst perplex wie verrückt sind
die denn und dann aber auch eine sorge
ich kann vielleicht sogar sagen eine
angst aus weil da schimmert schon wieder
durch was war bei corona erlitten haben
der staat maßt sich an in andere
lebensbereiche hier geschäft bald auch
privat rhein zu regeln kurzum robert
habeck dieser sympathische mann mit
denen manchmal verwuschelten haaren der
das so nett in seinem in seiner
pressekonferenz herumsitzt plant nichts
anderes als den klima lockdown wir reden
immer über lauterbach und machte jetzt
wieder den corona locker und so in
wahrheit droht uns der haarwäsche klima
lockdown und das ist das erste signal
das erste zeichen dafür dass hier etwas
im gange ist wo man sehr früh sagen muss
nein nicht mit uns wie ist jetzt deine
reaktion also führt das zu dem gegenteil
du drehst die heizung jetzt mal
scherzhaft nochmal doppelt auf die fünf-
und lässt es richtig heiß oder sagst du
okay mich interessiert das alles nicht
verordnung beiseite ich weiß genau für
mich selbst wie ich die nächsten monate
sparsam durch haben also ganz ehrlich zu
sein ich weiß es selber noch nicht aber
ich denke darüber nach und ich wünsche
mir in einem freien land dass ich meine
entscheidung treffen kann für mich und
die ist dann halt so oder so und was das
was für mich dadurch schimmert ist und
achtung jetzt werdet ihr gleich sagen ja
jetzt übertreibt er aber ganz schön ich
sehe auch als nächsten schritt in zwei
ordnungsamt beamte die nachts um 22 uhr
durch siedlungen muss kontrollieren
sagen da oben im zweiten stock sind die
fenster gekippt da brennen natürlich
kurz mal in unseren verordnungs katalog
drucken
25 euro schreiben wir mal ein knöllchen
wie bei falschparken ich sehe auch
weihnachtsbaum polizisten vor mir die
kommen und sagen was den weihnachtsbaum
mit elektro beleuchtung in diesem jahr
und den machen die schon um 17 uhr an
und erst um 21 uhr aus lasst uns mal in
unser buch gucken 50 euro pro kerze ja
wenn man jetzt denkt war was ist das
denn für eine bizarre übertreibung ich
selber als ich darüber nachgedacht habe
mir gedacht der kannst du das jetzt
bringen und dann ist mir eingefallen
wenn wir uns an dieser stelle vor zwei
jahren darüber unterhalten hätten dass
seine zeit kommt wo man um 22 uhr mit
seinem hund nicht mehr raus darf eine
ausgangssperre ist wegen corona dann
hätten wir auch gesagt man sitzt du denn
für ein typ in seinem blauen hemd und
einem hellgrauen sakko und erzählt was
erzählt dafür übertriebene sache ich
glaube wir haben bei corona erlebt was
jetzt beim klima ausgespielt wird und da
müssen wir frühzeitig sagen liebe
politiker nicht mit uns wir entscheiden
über unser geld und uns über unsere
energieausgaben selbst du sagst es
gerade corona jetzt das klima kann es
sein dass die politik gefallen daran
findet immer mehr in unsere privaten
entscheidungen noch einzugreifen ich
glaube dass das das training war was die
politik werden corona schritt für
schritt solle schritt für schritt immer
weiter hochgefahren gelernt hat und sie
hat gefallen daran gefunden und eine
linke regierung wir haben ja bei allem
respekt vor christian lindner eine linke
regierung mit einem mini mini mini
dimmer da drin das nicht ganz so schlimm
wird ist die fdp aber wir haben eine
rot-grüne regierung und diese idee dass
der staat besser weiß wie der einzelne
dass der staat sich dadurch eher
emanzipiert und legitimiert führt ins
leben der einzelnen einzugreifen das
werden wir hier wenn wir nicht aufpassen
wieder erleben und da müssen wir sehr
früh sagen das kann so nicht gehen denn
das rollenspiel ist doch anders haha
pack soll dafür sorgen dass unsere
gasspeicher voll sind das ist sein job
und mein job ist aufzupassen dass ich
mit meinem geld für energie hinkommen
und der job des ladenbesitzers der jetzt
seine türen nicht mehr aufmachen darf
wenn es nach habe geht ist es dafür zu
sagen dass er mit seinen energiekosten
ein gutes preisniveau für seine kunden
hingelegt und weiter deren händler des
vertrauens bleibt so ist die spielregeln
in einer freien demokratie des anderes
sozialismus punkt claus strunz ist aber
noch lange nicht schluss denn da kommt
der nächste um die ecke friedrich
winfried kretschmann baden württembergs
ministerpräsident der sagt heute man
muss doch nicht dauernd duschen auch der
waschlappen ist doch eine brauchbare
erfindung hat er sich eigentlich kann
man das ernst meinen wenn man so einen
vorschlag sagt ich weiß gar nicht also
da redet jetzt wirklich irgendwie opa
opa zu den kinder hier habe ich also das
ist wirklich ich meine das jetzt gar
nicht in einer art von alters
diffamierung sondern die tonalität und
die erzählweise das ist liebe kinderchen
gemeint sind übrigens die bürger
erwachsene leute die geld verdienen die
für ihre eigenen kinder zuständig sind
die ein leben leben mit allen chancen
liebe kinder hätten da draußen nehmt
doch mal was lampen und duscht nicht
immer da kann ich nur sagen die politik
ist gut dabei sich noch einmal zu
übertreffen den irrsinn den sie in der
im umgang mit den bürgern während
corolla schon ausgespielt hat und
ausgelebt hat nochmal zu toppen und ganz
offensichtlich duellieren sich winfried
kretschmann und robert habeck um die
nummer eins sagt bild chef claus strunz
hierbei bild live nachdem corona
lockdown kommt der klima lockdown
fürchtete er
[Musik]